hey guys it's Justine happy Easter to
celebrates I thought I would record just
some game player for you because I have
no other videos to post so let's
freaking celebrate by showing you guys
what's up on my animal cross island and
Easter is one of my favorite holidays
and I'm so sad because I always go home
to visit my family and my sister has a
baby and I don't get to see the little
baby she's so sweet and so cute here she
is
that's Brynn she didn't even get to sit
on the Easter Bunny's lap this year so I
guess she'll have her first Easter next
year remember laying this game you know
that there have been eggs that've been
dropping all over the island and I'm
absolutely so sick of it and I'm so 100%
over it but I created this little guy
this was one of the things we had to
create and then you gave him all the
Easter eggs he gives you a basket and
this is another DIY at recipe he gets
use those boys
if you're playing this game you've
probably already done this so this is
all stuff that I've created out of the
outfits from all the eggs I thought I
would show them off because what else do
I have to do I'm sure I could be doing
something else
the question is do I want to do anything
else
yeah I guess I'll just show you guys
what's been happening on my islands
since the last time that you guys have
seen it it's been quite a while I'm
actually collecting this is my third one
of these because when flip comes to
visit or flick flip flick the bug
catching dude you comes and he'll make
you like a little art piece I'll show
you what he made me if you collect three
of the same
he'll then make you like a little statue
this is what you made me maybe this man
faced mustachio so I want to get one
maybe from this thing but poor kid
mantis is really great so I guess let's
just start from over here some of my
villagers I've got this chicken his name
is Knox and he does weird stuff he goes
around the island just being weird I
don't know how to explain it it's
basically like a funeral home I think
that there's bodies in here
those are coffins and then he's licking
his freaking lollipop I don't even look
what is he doing I want him to say
something I don't have any bug hair you
put them in your belly so this is Knox
he does weird stuff so that's why I
jailed his outside of his house I just I
don't trust him guys I don't trust him
at all and this is kid I love kid kid is
like an obsessive cleaner so he just
goes around in his queening all the time
he's a musician but even a little
microphone and earlier today I went and
replanted all my trees I spent probably
that's actually let's see how many hours
I've played I've laid for 140 hours or
more I have really nothing to show for
it and nothing to show for it except
this pig knows where my sister Bobby and
this whole egg outfit I also realized
that I was not pressing a the whole time
that I was catching scorpions so thank
you to everybody and by everybody I mean
everybody who let me know that I need
press a to sneak I usually sticking
stuff all over the island because
Isabelle gave me a ranking of two and
I'm gonna be honest with you I was
really hurt because I know a little much
time I've been spending on this game in
the cockpit she made me a - oh my
darling is pretty upset these are some
more fruit trees these are some money
trees that's why they're all worked off
that's also a money tree that's why it's
right in front of here and I started
doing some attempts at breeding flowers
I would say that I bred but I did not I
got them from him I'll stick it on an
island and I just got to pick them and
put them there these ones I did breed
some got them all laid out and like the
X pattern is supposed to optimize
the breeding of tree flowers I don't
know I read it on the internet it seems
to be working for me quite well no new
ones since I last checked 5 minutes ago
so that's unfortunate I was running to
lay my Island out very strategically
like line all the houses that I gave any
the rest of the land to just do stuff on
is it a good idea I don't know just been
sticking stuff everywhere like it's
actually quite a disastrous mess and it
makes me so sad to know how much time
I've put into this and I don't really
feel like I'm happy with what I've done
I've seen some people's eyelids they're
so beautiful and minds of freakin just
it's a pigsty very fitting for my big
nose that my sister bought me this
phrase Tina because I mean yes she's
really cool so that's that side of the
island we've got
our little shops here I cannot even be
bothered to talk to him because he's
been haunting my dreams but these eggs
that are dropping eventually I'll remove
these little labels on here but I'm
trying to figure out where I want to
replant them too and I'm saving these
for Ed's fossil swap I kept selling them
so I needed money hey rocket is Rockets
birthday on the 14th that's soon I have
in my calendar I've started putting my
fake friends from the game they're not
fake friends the real friends they're
just you know like real if you play this
game you understand if you don't play it
then you don't understand I've got two
these matching brick bridges built this
is a nice little portrait that I've been
working on I planted all of these trees
so close together and then they didn't
grow so it left me with the dilemma of
having to go and maybe plant some up
above here I think the trees are
starting to change colors because I'm in
the southern hemisphere installed I have
any cherry blossoms
outside nothing is growing I came back
like several days alike these are
growing so much time what am I doing
with my life
I don't know I don't know what's
happening up here I honestly don't know
okay I just like a nice little park area
I also replanted all of these trees to
be nicely straight here's a quarter body
we're gonna get open I thank you but you
should be able to if you get to see it I
got my lighthouse up there we will pass
the campsite first which basically looks
like a big trash heap there's just
look at all these pink flowers I have I
got most of these on enough miles ticket
from somewhere else
on one of those Islands but I did read
some of those I liked my little house
area let me show you my house I was so
proud of my house and I wanted to do a
house tour to show you guys but then it
slowly just kind of started falling
apart and I just started running out of
storage so I had to put stuff everywhere
this did look a little better now it's
getting a little cluttered but I'm still
pretty happy with you know how things
are progressing but a lot of the stuff
I'm going to move into my other room
which I just got yesterday and you guys
can see I can't even get in there
because I've got it blocked by some
stuff but that's gonna be a whole nother
process let me show you what happens
when you run out of storage
I just dropped everything that I had in
to this room there's not even a single
bit of space to put anything else is
there pizza
what kind of food is in that oven and
then microwave it looks good with a cake
my other room I also was working on some
stuff so I kind of want to turn this
little set here into like one separate
room so it'll be like my office I paid
34,000 bells for that camera
and Edie actually bought it from one of
his friends islands and then he brought
it to me and then I paid him thirty four
thousand bills for it so that's
something that's been happening this is
I don't know I have no idea just stop
sure but I do like my little Promax
little uh little sign up there that's my
flag I haven't even gone into my other
room yet let's just let's just go in and
see what's up
look at this a new fresh room to do
whatever I want I have so much stuff in
my storage I've been obsessed with
customizing thing mystic man I can't
can't customize those desks that sucks
I would probably go nice in that other
room that I have this is coming together
nicely well I'll work on that just stuff
I have it's just a lot of stuff this is
my favorite I got this from the fishing
tournament what am I gonna do with that
what am I gonna want that I don't want
that but okay what
oh so freakin cozy see what this looks
like that's cool but like I don't think
that it's really fitting the vibe that
I'm going for her but I'd like to show
you guys you remember where we started
from in the last episode I just have a
lot of stuff before it was even worse I
had so much stuff everywhere that I
couldn't actually walk I'd have a mixer
on the floor and now we're here I also
don't like this welcome mat where did
that come from
what did I just take down that back up
there I don't like this welcome mat but
it was kind of cool so I just stuck it
there I also there's so much stuff I
need to do okay let's just get out of
here Oh over here you guys might
remember I had a little flea market I
have so many recipes that I don't need
anymore so I just keep dropping me off
like duplicate things he has any
suggestions for anything kk slider was
supposed to be here two days ago but
yesterday was the fishing tournament and
today is the bunny event so guess what
TK is not here yet I've been collecting
a Miro since the beginning so ever since
they were announced two years ago it's
been just something that
but a lot of time money and effort in
particular kidding so these are the
Animal Crossing amiibo cards and these
are some of the amiibo characters I
haven't invited any of good character
characters and what if we can do a
villager I think I can bring him in
basically you go to be a little ATM and
then you can choose to invite a camper
into your your campsite so yeah I want
to invite here
that's the villager in me though maybe
why can't he go to my dam site well I
got I'd already picked something that I
wanted I've already invited Muffy Rolfe
okay I think I'm going to invite
meringue because meringue looks cool
place it right here use NFC Next to move
here and meringue is on her way yes
you've got to be interested I'm trying
to keep track of the ones that I've
invited because then if you invite them
back they potentially will move to your
Island so this is the campsite and this
is where the amiibo are brought into and
then here we have meringue hanging out
and hopefully she gives me a DIY and
then I go make whatever it is that she
wants great lastly okay wouldn't it
[Music]
already just for you a little pink radio
I love the idea bringing a wooden tool
box home do you really a Victorian dress
oh okay hello I'm into that
I look good but I'm celebrating Easter
today so I have to put my egg party
dress back on sorry
and that's it so I hope that you're
having a good Easter I'm having as good
of one as I possibly can I made myself
breakfast this morning
some eggs go figure and you know I'm
gonna probably continue playing this
game and have another gourbin mate' and
call it a day
Happy Easter I love you guys and let me
know if you have any other suggestions
for things I should do my island
god what a mess I just I need to do it
overall but that's gonna be here I'm
just gonna wait until I get terraforming
so that maybe we can do a little
landscaping all right that's it I'll see
you later bye